ah yes
can we just stop though and talk about
for real this is incredible Adnan Syed
is is like they just go 20 years later
they just go
Psych
yeah I'm gonna go get a Big Mac or
anything whatever
Adnan Saeed 20 years later they go
Psych
he was he was they they said he killed
his girlfriend
um
you know poor girl
bro and like the prosecution
was just like not given all the info out
why are they do I I guess it was 1999 so
they didn't know that people were going
to get exposed right because the
internet was just new but like oh hey
Min Lee
but like dude you're gonna get caught
and dude Adnan Syed didn't do it and
there's proof now they didn't even have
a re-trial they were just like
oh dude we actually can release him
um based on the psych clause
we just issued him and we've got a court
ordered oopsie Daisy
and if we just get Adnan and his guys to
sign right here we're just gonna we're
not even gonna try him again we're just
gonna throw it out because of the psych
clause
anyway sign there and then the judge can
judge can we get you to write an Oopsy
Daisy please
and I add 9 Syed is gone dude
and uh
just [ __ ] tossed it out
that's [ __ ] crazy bro give him
millions and they just passed a [ __ ]
thing too where they're like oh well we
can't
there's some loophole where if they just
let them out or something and don't
admit fault
they ca he can't sue him and I'm just
like
first he's first of all he has a whole
life he's like 40 right
dude
Sue those where is it Baltimore sue them
dude Baltimore's got no money you know
get the rest of it and wrap Baltimore up
that's it dude Baltimore the city of
Baltimore should just be like ah we
[ __ ] up here's all the here here give
it to him in briefcase just whatever you
have left just get we're actually in a
lot of debt we want to transfer the debt
over to you too but the [ __ ]
according to the the psych the psych
clause and the judge signed the Oopsy
Daisy we can't do that so here's the
rest we have left we have 13
586 dollars
and that's a wrap for Baltimore dude
that's it that's it we just became
[ __ ] Richmond real quick or
whatever's close we're now part of
Washington DC I don't even know
we're Orange in New Jersey
uh we we're not [ __ ] it we [ __ ] up
dude we try we were trying so hard and
now we [ __ ] up with that and on Syed
[ __ ] they're not even the killer we're
not even gonna get the real killers
we're [ __ ] we have no money Adnan if you
want to find them and shoot them like
100 Hunger Games go for it there's no
laws because Baltimore doesn't exist
anymore
oh [ __ ] dude I mean real talk man I
would
my god dude if I got in
like imagine being [ __ ] dude there
like what's the percentage of people who
are wrongfully convicted it's like too
high what one is too high but like
imagine bro and you come out in 20 years
dude I'm killing everybody
I'm Deadpool oh well well I got how many
killings can I do now what what do I
have stacked right
like what what I've got some uh uh what
do you call it you got debt with me
how many cars what do you get for
robbing a bank
15 years I'm gonna rob a bank and have
five years left over what can I do can I
like uh what do I get to do I can
[ __ ] smack a few people I don't like
right so let me do that I'll tell you
what I'll rob a bank look the other way
and then I'm gonna go smack a few people
not in the bank robbery that doesn't get
all of that is with the bankrupt so
that's what I get now and that dude
[ __ ] gets the 13 586 at Baltimore
game [ __ ] gets to rob a bank and
smack a few [ __ ]
because this dude I mean he might have
missed his parents Diane this dude might
have missed you know what I mean no he
could have been a family man and had a
kid that's my heart man my heart breaks
for that [ __ ]
Court Judge Melissa Finn ordered that
science conviction be vacated and she
approved the release of the oopsie Davey
affidavit
um now 20 41 year old who I spent more
than two decades Behind Bars Jesus
Christ
Finn ruled that here he gets to rob a
bank make 13 586 and also smack four
people
congratulations
[Music]
[Music]